(jazz music)
(engine revving)
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] The new hospital
marks notable a advance
in Negro hospitalization.
A field which I regret to say
has been sadly neglected in
many sections of our country.
There have been 11 PWA Hospital
Projects for Negro patients
including Homer G. Phillips
which I am told is the largest
and finest of its kind in the
world.
The new building will
give the Negros a chance
to assert themselves in
medicine and surgery.
The fact that the splendid
structure
has been dedicated to the Negro
race,
is definite proof of the
friendly feeling
and the lessening of racial
prejudice,
now existing in this great city
and state.
Its real significance is that
at once and the same time,
it symbolizes the just demands
and needs of our Negro citizens,
and the willingness of the
part of those in authority,
to help achieve your rightful
place in our economic system.
- [Narrator] To understand
why the grand opening
of Homer G. Phillips Hospital
was such a significant event
you first need to know a little
bit
about the history of St. Louis.
Homer G. Phillips Hospital is
proof
of how the excellence of
a few affected so many.
- When you look at the
history of St. Louis,
around 1905 through 1930,
it was a time when a lot
of those organizations,
civic organizations were
fighting.
But it wasn't just in St. Louis
it was all over the country.
Is what I call a 100 years
of emancipation without freedom.
You know, emancipated in
1865, and people had to fight
all the way to 1965 before
all those basic freedoms
and given the same kind
of rights and benefits
that everybody else has.
- We were in the Jim Crow era in
Missouri,
which, you know, certainly
is a border state, right?
So you know, we aren't
in the deep South,
but certainly we're sort of
still thinking
about black folks were not
treated equitably here, right?
Like it was sort of, the vision
was to get
across the river to Illinois,
and that was a sort of the true
North.
- St. Louis was certainly one
of the most segregated cities
in the United States after the
civil war,
because of the black
migration from the South,
that took place and a lot
of blacks moved north,
along the Mississippi river
and St. Louis was one of
the stopping off points.
One of the important things was
that
St. Louis was so segregated
because the blacks were
in one area of St. Louis,
Italians in the other
and Germans on the other.
- Well The Ville was on
the outskirts of St. Louis.
It originally was not part of
the city.
And it belonged to a white
florist
and he had a race track, and he
had an inn
where people would stop off,
you know, in Ellettsville
at first, that's the original
name.
And it was shortened
over time to The Ville.
- So The Ville was actually,
it was a stable community.
It was very stable,
very well known African
American community.
And it was the site of the first
African American high school
west of Mississippi, Sumner.
- We had Poro College, which
was one of the first schools
for the training of African
American women
in the beauty culture business.
Chuck Berry also was a student
at that school I understand.
- [Robin] Annie Malone Home,
she was one of the first
black female entrepreneurs
in the United States.
Created a foster care
home for black children.
- We had Turner School
for handicap youngsters,
built in 1925, the
first school of its kind
for African American youngsters
in the United States.
I think one important
thing to remember is that
many of the people who worked
in The Ville lived The Ville.
And so you had a climate
where you had the workers,
plus the professionals all
intermingling,
attending church together,
seeing each other on a daily
basis,
which made it a special place to
live.
- Nowadays, they always talk
about a walkable community,
The Ville was the original
walkable community.
We had everything we
needed in our community.
So we're talking about a
segregated neighborhood,
but the key was that we had a
diverse population of people
in there from different income
levels.
We could walk anywhere, to the
store, we had grocery stores,
we had fresh fruit and vegetable
stands,
we even had a movie theater in
the Poro.
- The neighborhoods were
black neighborhoods.
There was the black
doctor, the black lawyer,
the black administrators,
folks lived in the same
neighborhood.
So it gave us an opportunity
to see professionals,
to see tradesmen, to see
business owners,
actually interact in
their own neighborhood.
We had these role models that
were there,
certainly was segregated,
certainly as Missouri,
certainly it's just north
of the Mason-Dixon line.
But at the end of the day,
we had an opportunity to
just be kids growing up
in a community that looked like
us.
- That's almost nonexistent
today
because what we've gone is
we've gone to the malls.
So when you go to the malls,
people are coming from
neighborhoods they don't live in
and getting service
whereas when I was a kid,
didn't have unemployment, why?
Because all of the stores and
things
that was in your community
had to hire people
who lived in the community
to service these people.
(jazz music)
- The Ville being less than a
square mile,
it made it a community
where people felt connected,
Money stayed in the
community a number of times
before it disappeared.
I think that's important to
remember
because you build wealth in a
community
by wealth staying in the
community.
And I think another thing,
it's good to remember,
it thrived because others
couldn't.
And let me explain that,
many of the teachers and
professionals
were forced by segregation
to work in the community.
So many of the people who
lived here got the best
because they couldn't get the
best.
Another thing that
happened during that time,
teachers were not allowed to get
married.
So many of the students
became their family.
- Doctors, they couldn't
get married on that time.
And my uncle really who became
medical director later on,
married my aunt Dorothy,
who was a school teacher,
but they had to keep it
hidden during the time.
They were married for
the first four years.
It was just thought the
doctors couldn't perform
their duties if they were
married early
or school teachers, were thought
that they couldn't perform
as a school teacher if they had
a husband.
I don't know why the social
structure was like that,
but that's the way it was.
- Teachers, doctors, lawyers,
businessmen,
prominent businessmen,
all lived in The Ville.
It was a thriving community
with people making money,
and most of the stores and
all the business places
were owned by black people.
This was great to live in The
Ville.
We made movie there, Poro Hotel.
Annie Malone, Annie Malone, so
Annie started the Poro Hotel.
And when you wanted to be an
attorney,
the only place that you could
go was Lincoln University
and Lincoln did not have a law
school
so they started the law
school in the Poro Hotel,
and black attorneys taught
young men to be attorneys.
So this all happened at the
Poro Hotel in The Ville.
- I went to Sumner High
School and across street
from my high school was
the teacher's college.
Around the corner
was the branch of Lincoln
University's Law School.
So we saw students who
were becoming lawyers.
So what I saw as a high school
student
is us are the extension of
education that let me know that
where I was going to high
school four years later
was not the end of my
educational system,
but it was the springboard
because I saw other
people going to college,
working on a PhD, that looked
good to me.
They looked like champions
of the community.
(tense music)
- Attorney Homer G. Phillips
is sort of an enigmatic
historical figure.
Many people know certain
elements of his life,
but there's a lot more
that hasn't been discovered
about attorney Homer G.
Phillips.
He was born John Wesley
Phillips, I do have evidence.
There's a small annotation in a
newspaper
from Sedalia around 1899,
that announces that a John
Wesley Phillips
has changed his name to Homer G.
Phillips,
Homer Garland Phillips.
I think that sort of name change
preceded his matriculation to
Howard University Law School.
Many people don't know that
attorney Homer G. Phillips
was a staunch advocate
for civil rights, black civil
rights.
He was a staunch advocate
for black voting,
he was a staunch Republican
activist,
he helped get President
Herbert Hoover elected
in the Midwest region.
He was also a staunch
advocate for equal rights,
and particularly working
against sort of rising
segregation policies in the
city.
So Homer G. really fought
against the implementation
of Deed Restrictive
Covenants, for instance.
Homer G. actually was
instrumental
in securing over $200,000 in
relief for those black families
who were affected in the East
St. Louis Race Riot in 1917.
And that itself really
sort of catapulted him to
not only the local recognition,
but also national recognition.
- Very, very popular man in St.
Louis.
They wanted him even to run for
mayor,
the city of St. Louis during
those times.
And I think if he ran, he was
probably,
probably he would have won
becoming the first African
American mayor
in the City of St. Louis in the
1930s.
- Homer G. Phillips was one of
the many,
many African Americans whose
parents
came out of the civil war,
got a taste of freedom in
times of the reconstruction,
when the 13, 14 and 15
amendments of the constitution
were passed, abolished
slavery, granted citizenship
and call for equal
treatment of all citizens.
The opportunity to build a black
family,
became a lot more or realistic
with the end of slavery.
Because one of the major
aspects of slavery,
is they made a precise attack
on that basic unit of social
organization, the black family,
where you sell the child
this way, the mother that way
and the father that way,
you create an incredible
crisis for those family
from which we have never fully
recovered.
So you have to see Homer G.
Phillips as one of the products
that came out of that
reconstruction era.
- He was an attorney, a
very prominent attorney,
who had a strong sense of social
justice.
And he had lent his name and his
expertise
to a number of projects
in the neighborhood
of uplifting in the community.
He had a particular interest in
health,
and I'm not so sure why,
but this was a subject
that just really caught his
attention.
- Not only was Homer G. a
lawyer,
he was also involved in
distributing low interest loans
to African American community
members
and he was also a part of
the newspaper business.
So he was a part of the
newspaper business
in Sedalia, Missouri, his
hometown.
But he also was a partner in
newspapers here in St. Louis,
so particularly the St. Louis
Argus,
which was one of the first
African American newspapers
in St. Louis.
But then he began to sort of
switch
and began to work with judge
Nathan Young
later on in his life when he
realized
that there's a sort of massive
transition
happening among black voters,
namely that black voters were
switching
from the Republican Party to
the Democratic Party, right?
And so the St. Louis Argus
and the St. Louis American,
and Homer G.'s interaction
with both of those,
actually mirrors that sort of
transition.
- The newspaper business
was extremely relevant
in the African American
community earlier,
particularly when we
had this great migration
from the South.
I was always interested in
public policy
because I thought that had
an impact on people's lives.
And I thought that
having a black newspaper
would enable me to have some
impact.
National Trade Association
has called us the number
one black newspaper
in the country in the last six
years,
with the largest weekly
newspaper of any kind
in the State of Missouri.
So I'm very proud of what has
happened with an institution
that was started in 1928.
Homer Phillips was a lawyer and
activist
who we admire a great deal here,
was a part of the original
ownership
of the St. Louis American.
And I would say Homer Phillips,
the person who was held in
high esteem by his community,
we've tried to use that
as sort of an example,
a model for how we should
conduct ourselves as a
newspaper.
- He was also very active in
getting the African Americans
elected to public office.
He supported a bond issue,
$8 million bond issue,
with the understanding that $1
million
would go for construction of a
hospital
for African Americans that would
be run by African Americans
and operated by them.
He wanted it to be a
community control hospital.
And he wanted it to be in the
African American community
- City Beautiful bond by mayor
Henry Keel,
was a massive infrastructure
plan,
over $80 million to improve
city infrastructure,
to provide new buildings for the
city
and that's the time when
you have black doctors
who are beginning to say
they needed a place to train.
They needed a place
where they could sharpen
their medical skills,
where they could get access to
patients
and where they could really
become
higher echelon physicians,
meaning specialized physicians
which requires extra years of
training.
Originally, Homer G. Phillips
was actually opposed to
a segregated hospital.
He did not advocate for
any type of segregation
and that included segregation in
hospitals
which sort of goes against kind
of
the popular understanding
of Homer G., right?
That he led the movement to get
Homer G. Phillips Hospital
started.
That eventually happened.
But initially Homer G. actually
would have preferred that
the two City Hospitals
in St. Louis actually be
integrated.
But when the city sort of said
we're going to stick with
segregation
against segregation policies
that are being implemented
at this exact same time that
were not there before, right?
This is due in part to
sort of black migration
from the rural South.
I mean people are coming through
St. Louis stopping there.
So the black population
is expanding rapidly
and the old City Hospital
for African American,
City Hospital number two, was
not enough,
- And this was people's hospital
that was totally inadequate.
And also they put blacks in
the City Hospital number one
in the basement behind the steam
pipes.
So because of the poor care
that blacks were getting there,
because St. Louis had a
large influx of blacks
from the South after slavery,
Homer G. Phillips thought
that this would be
the best thing to do to have a
hospital
totally built for the black
community.
- And so Homer G. was
instrumental in getting
a key provision in the 1923 bond
issue
for a Negro hospital.
There was debate about
whether that newer hospital
should be separate from
City Hospital number one,
if it should be close to
City Hospital number one.
- There were those who said
let's put it as an attachment,
an annex to the white hospital
under white administration.
He said no.
- And so Homer G. said
instead, and many agreed,
that if they weren't gonna have
a hospital
where they could practice
autonomously,
doctors and nurses could
practice autonomously
whereby patients could
have dignity, you know,
not to suffer the sort of
indignities of white physicians,
then they needed a
completely separate hospital.
- He went to the board of
aldermen
where it was finally decided
that it would be a separate
hospital
because they wanted to
renege on that at first.
- And that debate took 10 years.
So from the 1923 bond issue to
1933,
ground is initially being broken
on the Homer G. Phillips
Hospital.
- And all through that
time Jim Crow was raging.
(R&B music)
St. Louis City was extremely
segregated.
I'm talking about most black
folks were concentrated
east on the other side
of Jefferson Avenue.
Then it was Grant, then it was
King side
before they started expanding
West.
But the important point is
that shortly after the banish
was passed
Homer G. Phillips was
assassinated
right there on Delmar and
Euclid.
- It's unfortunate that he
didn't really live to see
his dream come to fruition,
because under mysterious
circumstances
he was shot by two gentlemen
on his way to his office on a
street car.
A murder which was
never solved by the way,
- Debates, you know, vary,
again,
according to why Homer G. was
murdered.
It seemed initially
that the two individuals
who were seen, witnessed
shooting Homer G. Phillips
shot him because of debates
about an estate check
that Homer G. would not
disburse to his client.
There was a dispute about
whether
the daughter of a man or
his sort of younger wife
would get the estate and
it was a sizeable estate,
I believe it was around $3,000.
Homer G. successfully secured
the money
for the daughter of this man,
but he charged $1,000 for his
fees.
They did not pay that fee.
And so it was assumed
that Homer G. was murdered
because he did not disburse
the whole of their check.
Two individuals were caught.
They were apprehended,
they were identified in lineups.
They were even brought to trial,
but neither were convicted of
the crime.
It's strange to me at least
and it's strange other people
that two young African American
men
who were witnessed
publicly shooting this man
were not convicted of the crime.
That's interesting to me.
- Of course the killer
was never apprehended
and of course, you know, if
you don't look for people,
you don't find them.
And I'm sure in those days, in
the circumstances behind it,
there was not a lot of looking
because it would have taken
effort to find
and that was not high
on the priority scale
as we would say now to
find out who killed him.
- I don't know either way.
I don't think there is
gonna be a definitive answer
as to why Homer G. was
assassinated, murdered,
however you wanna sort of
describe that.
But it is curious to me
that these two young men
who had arrest records before
this, right?
Were not convicted of the crime.
Were they paid?
No one knows.
I mean, you know, was this a
hit?
No one knows.
Was this really about the estate
check?
No one knows.
Because that case
was not closed,
I mean that really sort of paved
the way
to the institution itself being
named
after Homer G. Phillips.
- It is the number one most
prominent unsolved murder
in the history of the city of
St. Louis.
He paid a price for this
facility, paid with his life.
He's a kind of martyr that you
have to put
on the same level as Martin
Luther King,
you know, Malcolm X.,
and Homer G. Phillips.
Even though we don't speak
that much enough about him,
you will not find any monument
anywhere
outside of this facility
to the memory or to the
incredible contribution
of attorney Homer G. Phillips.
- Calls were immediately made
to name the hospital after
Homer G.
So right after his death, right?
And it seemed relevant to put
his name on this hospital.
But you do have individuals
like David Grant
who would later say naming
Homer G. Phillips Hospital
is actually a sort of
a double edged sword.
On the one end, it is certainly
an institution of pride.
It's a vision of progress,
particularly in this
neighborhood.
On the other hand, it still
was a segregated institution,
so even though the history of
segregation
has produced this sort of
jewel in history as it were,
you know, it's still a
segregated institution
and Homer G. fought
every type of segregation
tooth and nail,
and I wonder, you know,
were Homer G. alive today,
you know, what would he really
think
about his name being on this
institution?
- That was supposed to be
Colored Hospital Number Two
and of course, you know,
it was always number two.
I came from that era and I
understand one, two, A, B.
So I do not call those
hospitals.
I call them by their name.
I called City Hospital, not
City Hospital Number One,
but it was either City Hospital
or it was Max Starkloff
and Homer Phillips' hospital
was Homer G. Phillips Hospital
not City Hospital Number Two.
- Both sorta sentiments are
there.
They exist simultaneously.
It is important that we sort of
remember
this black lawyer at
this black institution,
but at the same time,
the circumstances that
produced this institution
themselves are deplorable.
(R&B music)
- When Homer G. Phillips opened
up,
it was a great day of
celebration.
Thousands filled the streets,
all dignitaries came,
the newspapers toasted as one of
the best
African American hospitals
in the community,
St. Louis and the world.
- Again, you have to
remember the time also.
This is 1937.
And this is a time when
when Roosevelt himself
is very anxious about the war
effort
and really reaching out to the
African American community.
Frankly, it may not
have been the president
as much as it was Eleanor
Roosevelt
who really was the driving
force for social change,
and so she perhaps was the
one who moved Harold Ickes,
who was secretary of the
interior
to support the Homer G. Phillips
Hospital.
And in fact, he was
here during the program
during the opening of the
hospital opening ceremony.
So it really was a national
event.
- The mayor of St. Louis
was there, Bernard Dickman.
But what's interesting about him
is that he actually sort
of, before he became mayor,
was involved in the St.
Louis real estate exchange,
which was heavily involved
in restricting housing in St.
Louis
and steering black and white
individuals
to different parts of the town.
So even though the mayor
celebrated this hospital
it's sort of also celebrated too
that he was able to build this
hospital
as opposed to his Republican
predecessor, Victor Miller.
The hospital project languished
for a decade under his
administration.
So in many ways, even though
Dickman
had this sort of strange
history,
I mean to sort of secure the
black vote,
which is really important in St.
Louis,
I mean he really sort of put his
efforts
to building this hospital.
You also had the governor,
you had state representatives,
and again, this also sort of
embodies
a sort of a new deal moment,
right?
You had these sort of, you know,
the public works administration,
the works progress
administration
were deeply involved
in helping to fund and
construct this hospital.
So the infusion of that money
allowed it to really become
one of the biggest black
hospitals
in the nation to be quite frank.
- Well, Homer G. Phillips
was very close to me
because my father was in
the first group of interns
to train in Homer G. Phillips.
The story goes that in 1937
when the hospital was built,
my father graduated from
Meharry Medical College
in Nashville, Tennessee
and he and 27 of his fellow
classmates
were on their way to Kansas City
to intern the Kansas City
General.
They had to change trains in St.
Louis
and while they were in the train
stations,
a red cap, which was the colored
porters
that put bags on a train,
asked them where they were
going.
They said, well, we're
going to Kansas City.
He said, well, they just
built a colored hospital here
and they don't have any doctors.
So they went out on a taxi
and checked at the hospital
and they all decided to stay
since it weren't bad with $10 a
month,
clothes and rolling board.
And that was the same thing
that was going on in Kansas
city.
So they became the first 27
interns at Homer G. Phillips.
- This was large.
Homer G. Phillips wasn't just a
hospital,
it was gonna be one of the
greatest
African American hospitals in
the country.
We had Hubbard hospital
and we had Howard hospital
and there were smaller
hospitals,
but nothing of this stature
had ever been conceptualized
or built for the African
American community
and so this was a huge
undertaking.
I think that just really was,
you know,
illustration of Homer
G. Phillips the attorney
of his broader vision
that he was gonna create
this momentous remarkable
hospital,
which was gonna be the training
program
for at least a third of all
African American physicians
between 1937 and 1979.
Just a remarkable feat in
itself.
Then we had a nurses
program, nursing school,
and there's a tunnel that
goes from a nursing school
all the way to the hospital
where you didn't have to go
outside.
- And because the facility was
so special,
they built the main hospital,
a nursing home and a power
plant,
and also an interns quarters.
The nursing home was built for
148 nurses
and the interns was housed,
I think it was 28 interns.
The hospital was built
to take care of 635 beds,
which was really something,
it was one of the largest
hospitals
in the country at the time.
- Again, although The
Ville was there beforehand,
Homer G. Phillips really put his
stamp,
his imprimatur on The Ville
and the two really were
just indistinguishable.
Homer G. was The Ville
and The Ville was Homer G.
- So by the time of the
hospital's dedication
the hospital was named
Homer G. Phillips Hospital
and the dedication ceremony,
one of the last items on the
program
was that city officials
handed the keys of a hospital
to the hospital's medical
director, Henry Hampton,
who was the first African
American
medical director of the
hospital.
- This is at the time of course
now
when during rigid segregation
in large parts of the country,
and it's fallacy that African
Americans
could not run a hospital.
African American doctors
could not deliver care
of the quality of whites.
Physicians, African American
nurses
could not deliver care the
way white nurses could.
And so Harry Hampton had this
knowledge
and he had every desire
to break that stereotype,
to produce a hospital
which was gonna be of the
highest quality
having the highest volume and
really creating innovation,
which will be adopted by white
hospitals.
In the first year from 1937 to
1938,
they had over 100,000 patients
visit.
Now The Ville neighborhood
is relatively small,
as you can imagine.
So you can see this is drawing
patients
from a large catchment area.
And Harry Hampton said, when
they walked through this door,
America's eyes are on us.
We're gonna show that we can do
this
and do this extraordinarily well
and this is what Henry Hampton
wanted,
this was his legacy.
He wanted people to remember
this
as a phenomenally great
hospital.
Not a phenomenally great black
hospital,
but a great hospital period.
- Then Dr. William Sinkler took
over
who was a sort of prolific
figure
in the history of the hospital
and really not only had
a hand in making sure
that the hospital itself ran
smoothly,
but also really helped to
develop
the internship and residency
programs.
- And it was through the
program that he set up,
that knowledge, it came from
Sinkler
and his knowhow and whatever
to all of the modalities
of general surgery.
And I was a privileged
to have a scrubbed with him
on several occasions.
In doing so you learn,
you watch his technique, how
he approached the problem,
what he did with the problem
and the outcome that he had
and all of it was very, very
admirable.
- You know, he was a
surgeon, and I was a pedi,
and we were on the fifth floor,
and they were on the second
or third floor I think.
And of course he had us over,
usually you didn't see him
unless
you were getting called on to
carve it,
first I knew of it.
(laughter)
- Well Dr. William H.
Sinkler was a classmate
of my father at Howard
university,
so they knew each other well.
He was small in stature,
he was about five foot six
and they called him little
Willy because he was so short,
but he had a step up on a
stool when they operated.
But Dr. Sinkler was a whizz at
surgery
so because of the poor care
that they had down South,
one of the pharmacists
down there, Dr. Pierce,
asked Dr. Sinkler when
he come down and operate
on some poorly taken care
of patients in Monroe.
So because it was a Catholic
hospital
and because it was segregated,
they wouldn't take or
operate on any patients
in Monroe that were black.
So Dr. Sinkler and Dr. Vaughn
went down to Monroe, Louisiana
to operate on these patients
that had been selected for them.
So when they get to Monroe,
they had to change the clothes
in the janitor's closet.
So when they went in the
operating room,
since they had several patients,
some of the patients needed
more than one operation to be
done.
One particular lady needed a
hysterectomy
and a gallbladder taken out,
which was unusual to do at the
same time,
so you'd expect the operation
to take a long time.
The white doctors in the
community gathered around a
table
to watch these doctors operate,
and because they had to be
operating pretty quickly,
they was just whizzing along
and the one of the white doctors
just couldn't contain himself
and said,
"Ooh-wee, look at these
little niggers go,"
and so that was a story that
just went around the hospital
and everybody just laughed
about how fast Dr. Sinkler was.
- When you think of, you know,
the legion of African American
physicians
from James Whittico to LaSalle
Leffall
who became president, the first
African American president
of the American Cancer Society.
These people are world renowned
and they were here at Homer G.
because there was this
sense of greater purpose.
We had to get the best to train
the best.
- [James] There was only three
places
in the United States where Negro
doctors
can get a qualified internship
and those three places were
Howard University, Washington
D.C.,
Meharry Medical College,
and then came Homer Phillips
Hospital,
and that was, fortunately
enough, the exception.
- Well, one of my favorite
stories was James Whittico
came to complete his
internship at Homer G. Phillips
and so he said when he drove his
car in,
he looked up and he saw
the hospital, he said.
- [James] I couldn't believe it,
I'd never seen a structure
that magnificent,
that large, and that new
and so I parked and just checked
it
and looked at this beautiful
hospital.
And I was just carried
away with
this great structure that ain't
never seen
anything like it before in my
life.
- Everyone who walked in
had that same feeling.
It just, it really was
breathtaking
the way it was structured,
the beauty of this hospital
and people wanted to be here.
- My sister, my daughter's
aunt, was a pediatrician.
She was there first
and she also trained at
Homer Phillips Hospital
and she was the main reason I
came.
- Dr. Helen Nash was a very
strong woman,
physician, pediatrician here in
St. Louis,
well known, very competent.
- My aunt Helen, her time spent
at Homer Phillips Hospital,
she was one of few women
residents there at the hospital
and I think in her internship
class,
maybe she was one of five or six
women
and she then did a residency
in pediatrics there
and one of her big
interests was in the care
of premature infants and
she did a lot to improve
the conditions in the nursery
at Homer Phillips Hospital
to have them kind of up to
the standard of nurseries,
you know, in other hospitals
across the country.
- I was on pediatrics with Dr.
Helen Nash
and as stated before,
everybody was afraid of her,
but she was excellent.
I was feeding a baby, laying on
his back
and she walked in and she told
me I was drowning the baby.
I have never fed a baby
laying flat on its back again.
I always sit it up straight
and I will never forget that.
- [Helen] Well, everybody came
to Homer G.
It was one of the best places.
They took the largest number of
interns
and you could be sure
of getting
a residency.
Pediatrics, that's what I wanted
to do
and so the major thing
was to get accepted here.
- One of the most
qualified women to finish
from Homer G. Phillips was Helen
Nash,
who was a pediatrician.
She and her brother Homer
both ran a practice of
pediatrics for at least 50 years
in the city of St. Louis.
She was one of the first blacks
to be on the staff of pediatrics
in St. Louis University.
Took care of the indigent
in St. Louis for years
and to this day I think
she was one of the best
pediatricians that I ever worked
with being an obstetrician.
I delivered the babies
that she took care of.
- So Helen Nash was a force of
nature.
She was a force of nature
because she had a chip on her
shoulder.
Her father said, "Helen, I
don't want you to be a doctor.
I want you to do something in
the arts."
She said, "Wait a minute, oh,
I'm a girl
and you don't want me to be
a doctor because I'm a female.
I'm not gonna buy that," and so
she said,
"No, I'm gonna be a doctor
whether you want me
to be a doctor or not."
And so she carried that,
she had something to prove to
herself,
you know, in a misogynistic
society,
she's gonna show that she's not
gonna be
just a doctor, but the doctor.
- Helen Nash is a legend
in this community.
I mean, I think she represented
maybe
second or third generation.
Her brother, her niece,
her dad were physicians
and everybody who knows her
career
holds her in the highest esteem.
She was a great pioneer.
She's one of several who
practice medicine
at a very high level and was
welcomed
into the more broad stream
of academic medicine.
- So Helen had a reputation
for being really, really feisty
and really, I used to say, you
know,
she didn't take any prisoners,
but what I meant by that
was that she was, you
know, it was her way,
and she stood up for what
she believed was right
and she was not gonna let anyone
tell her
she couldn't do what she
knew she was capable of
or should be allowed to
do, that sort of thing.
- She was incredibly
good with her patients,
her small patients or babies
and with the family members,
the things that she
did in order to improve
maternal child health.
- [Helen] Infant mortality rate,
morbidity and mortality
rates were very high
for infants all over the country
and the premature
infants at Homer Phillips
because there was no set up
prem-y unit
at the time had a death rate
above 80%.
- And she noticed that, well,
why are all these babies,
you know, in the same bed,
same crib when one's sneezing
and one could have the croup?
We should have separate
bassinets
for these kids, for these
babies.
Now you will say that, well,
that's pretty, you know,
obvious,
there's nothing sophisticated
about that.
It was, that was a novel
concept
and she did something simple
as to have individual bassinets.
The infection rates plummeted.
- Because of the groundwork
she laid because she had done so
well,
it made it easier for me to come
because I did not have to prove
things
that she had already proven
and they just sort of expected,
oh, this was another
person doing the same thing
and she was of course a
teacher and a mentor for me.
- One of the things that
was really important
for Helen is that her
patients were treated well.
- [Helen] I went to the diet
kitchen
and I asked the dietician
who had gotten to be a friend of
mine
why we never had ice cream
and we never had bananas
and she said, I will
show you the grocery list
that came from downtown,
and ice cream and bananas were
marked
by City Hospital only, the white
hospital.
I went to the medical director
and to the superintendent
who was McKnight,
the medical director was Dr.
Sinkler,
I said, "Can you imagine
that children on my ward
can't have ice cream
because they are black?"
He will say, "Miss Helen,
here you go again."
I said, "You have to have
ice cream and bananas
if you wanna look right."
Then they started to alternate.
Then they cause so much ruckus
that they just said everybody
have ice cream every day,
all you want, so forget it.
- Helen, Helen,
when she made up her mind,
you couldn't change it.
- She was the first
African American female
to join the staff at Washington
University
at the children's hospital.
- [Helen] I was in the new
newborn unit
scrubbed up in cap and gown
and I'm getting ready to
go into the newborn unit
to look at a baby and this
nurse came in and said,
"Oh, you're getting ready
to examine your grand baby."
I said, "You know very well
that I am Dr. Nash
and I'm not examining
any goddamn grand baby."
She got written up and she
came back later and said,
"I'm really sorry.
I know very well that you are
Dr. Nash."
I said, "Just you don't forget
it now.
The next time you see a
black doctor doing something,
you won't do that."
- Well, obviously we were
always brother and sister,
but professionally we
would have been fighting.
(laughter)
- Dr. Howard Venable is
another great example.
He was a very well recognized
African-American
ophthalmologist.
Many of these people really
became leaders
in their medical fields,
not just among black physicians,
but among all physicians,
right? So,
they would have sort of,
have positions in the
National Medical Association,
the black analog of the
American Medical Association.
To have high ranking positions
in the American Medical
Association,
to be widely regarded in
their specialty fields
is quite impressive.
I don't think you will find
that sort of, you know,
sort of storied cohort of alumni
from any other black hospital,
really.
- I look at the Homer G.
Phillips story
and it reminds me of the
Tuskegee Airmen.
Think about that, and are you,
you're telling someone
that they can't do it,
they can't be a fighter pilot,
that they can't compete?
Well, the woman and the men of
color
who walked through Homer
G. Phillips Hospital
were my Tuskegee Airmen.
They said, "Okay, world,
take a look at this, okay?
"Take a snapshot 'cause you're
not gonna,
this is gonna be something you,
we're gonna blow your socks
off.
We're gonna show you
how it should be done."
("This is How We Do It" by
Montell Jordan)
♪ This is how we do it
- Well Homer G. Phillips,
because it was a magnet for
talent,
people took great pride and
they wanted to be the best
and they were made to
feel proud by being here
and they still kept in touch
with these
long after they left.
Many of them stayed in St.
Louis,
many of the doctors I grew up
knowing
I became friends with them in
later life.
They stayed here.
- My history with Homer G.
Phillips
goes all the way back to infancy
because I grew up only a block
and a half
away from the hospital
and it was the main hospital in
the city.
In 1958 when I graduated,
the white hospitals had opened
up
and I applied for an internship
at Pontiac General Hospital
in Pontiac, Michigan.
Went there for a year and I
was gonna take a residency
in pathology and I got to
thinking
that I wanted to do
something to help people.
I didn't wanna have
dead people as patients
and I thought maybe,
there was no technology,
and I thought maybe I
needed to get into a field
where I could do something.
I mean, just not standing
around and watch people die
because we didn't know
what the diagnosis was.
I called my mother and asked her
if she would call her
brother, Dr. Gaitkins,
and if he would call Dr.
Sinkler, Dr. William Sinkler,
who was the head of
surgery at Homer Phillips
and Dr. Sinkler told my mother,
"Tell him to be here
July 1st at nine o'clock
in uniform ready to go to
work."
- You felt immediately
that you could relate
to the individual that was there
regardless of their stature
and the hospital was a staffed
completely,
that is in the medical aspect
and in the business aspect, by
blacks.
So you did, you felt quite at
home.
I think that feeling like
that is conducive to learning.
- The internship at the time,
'cause this is over rote
was called a rotating
internship,
in which you had to span
like three months on surgery,
three months on medicine,
two months on OB-GYN,
and then you have like
maybe one month of elective
like urology or ear, nose and
throat,
and maybe pathology.
So on my three months of
surgery,
I think I learned more surgery
than most people learned
around the country.
- Dr. Sinkler was medical
director at that time
and he had come to Howard
University
and met with students
who may be interested
and he told us if we wanted to
come there,
he would guarantee us that
we would have a position.
That's why I came to Homer
Phillips,
although I had known about it,
but there were no women
doctors of any race in my town.
So I didn't think that way.
I went to Howard to
major in home economics,
foods and nutrition, not
medicine,
but I think I was leaning that
way.
- So I came to Homer Phillips
Hospital
and the dental program was a
relatively minor program there,
but my own education there
was assisted very much
by the young physicians in
training.
So when I came there,
I was in my twenties,
as were most of the other young
people
but St. Louis at that time was
a much more vibrant city than it
is today
and of course the time I spent
in Homer Phillips Hospital
meant that I knew people about
my age
from around the country.
From as far west as California,
south as Louisiana, North
Carolina.
They all came here to
train surgical specialties.
I spent two years in St. Louis,
and then I went to the military.
I had an obligation.
(tense music)
- I served in the Navy in World
War II
and I went in I think it was
at the height of the war,
war was really going on
strongly at that time
and they were drafting everyone
that would turn 18 years of age.
So I turned 18 and did
not get to go to my prom
because I had received
a letter in the mailbox
saying greetings, and you're to
come
and have an examination.
Went up to Chicago, Illinois,
and had the examination
and when I got back,
I had my induction notice in the
mailbox,
it was that quick.
- After my internship from
1963-'64,
I started my residency
July the 1st
of 1964,
gonna make sure I get these
dates correct.
Then I was interrupted.
I was drafted in 1966.
I came back in '68 and finished
in '69.
- January of 1967.
It was cold, it was about 10
below zero
and my wife called me and said,
"You got a strange letter here,
I don't know what it means."
I said, "Well, open it up," and
she says,
"It's from the United States
government,
and it says greetings from the
President
of the United States."
That was how they drafted
your back in the days
and so I got drafted.
Mario was my son, he was
almost four
and we adjusted to it.
I just, I went.
- I didn't want to choose
medicine.
I preferred chemistry, I
wanted to be a chemist,
but they were not hiring
any black chemists.
I had the top honors in
chemistry at Howard university.
So I noticed that the fellows
who went to medical school
were not going to Korea.
So I said, well, I guess I
better go down there then,
I don't wanna go in military as
a private.
Yeah, I was chief of
surgery in Ozen, Korea,
one of the most significant
things that I accomplished
was integrating the air force
hospital.
The Koreans who would get hit
around
and they wouldn't let them,
we could not admit them,
but I did admit one and
the colonel came in,
said I couldn't do that.
And so I told him what
reasons I had.
No point in sending him out to
die
when we could take care
of him and he told me,
"Sit down." He said
"Well, Jackson,
you guys vote tonight and if
y'all decide
to treat this here Korean,
I'm not gonna stand in your
way."
So that night we were
all draftees, you know,
basically we've already admit
the Korean.
- So my dad was in medical
school
during World War II
during the draft for World War
II,
and during that time they
allowed him
to join the service and
continue with medical school.
So he spent his time in medical
school
in his last year of medical
as part of being in the army.
After that, he completed
his medical training,
completed his residency,
spent a year in Chicago.
Then during the Korean War
that he was called back
into military service
and that was quite a
disruptive event for him.
Fortunately for him, they sent
him to a pediatric hospital
in Wurtzburg where he met our
mother
who was working as a
nurse there in the wards
and they were married in
Germany.
And then came back and
took up his practice
and they worked together to
reestablish
his practice in Los Angeles.
- Well, well during my residency
where I became friends with
quite a few,
but I remember some more
than others of course,
you know, Robinson, Oliver Page,
McDonald,
we were all residents.
Some of us who are in different
fields.
- Yeah, we met when we were
young kids.
- At the YMCA camp.
- The Camp River Cliff.
So it turned out that I loved
camp.
He couldn't stand it cause
he always wanted to eat
and he went home to his mom
after 10 days.
- No, they wouldn't come and get
me now.
- They would come.
- I called every day.
They let you make one phone call
a day
and I called home to ask
of them to come and get me
and they wouldn't do it.
- So this is how we first hooked
up
and then years passed and
we didn't see each other
and then we came back as friends
later on at Homer G. Phillips.
- Now I remember Dr.
Robinson and Dr. MacDonald
because as I had said before,
we did a rotating internship.
So as spent I guess
four months on surgery,
two months on female surgery,
two months on male surgery
and we were of course interns
and they were the residents.
So we were allowed the first
line to draw the blood,
take the history, write up
everything,
as they used to call it the
quote scutwork
and get the patients
ready for the residents.
And I can remember,
Dr. McDonald and I,
at three o'clock in the
morning on a Saturday night
or early Sunday morning.
We had tried to put a
300 pound man on slab
so we could do an arteriogram
and he was just about as small
as I,
but I think we finally got it
done.
It took about three
hours 'cause the patient
would not help us because
he was shot by the police
so he wasn't doing a thing.
- We had a poker game that we
would play
on the fifth floor,
and we'd get paid I think
the first of the month,
and about three days after that,
all the money was gone.
So we couldn't put any money in
the pot
and we would play what
we called on the finger.
- The public game ran on
Fridays,
on payday till the money ran
out.
It may run for three or four
hours
or it may run all the way to
Saturday
and then we started playing for
credit.
We called it betting on the
finger
where, "I owe this money,
I bet you $50, I raise
your $100 on the finger,
I ain't got $100, but it
will be in the pot later on."
- We would keep record
of the fingers in the pot
and then we'd have to settle
up when the next pay day came.
- There was still
several bars around there
that we would frequent.
I know I remember one
called the Nutty Pine
you know, we'd go there
early in the morning,
sometimes we finished a round.
- Course, as soon as we
left work, we went to a bar.
We had our favorite hang outs,
Sorento, the Pine Nut,
what was that little place we'd
hang out?
Ruby's Zodiac Lounge
over in East St. Louis.
All the clubs, the Files Club,
the Manhattan.
- I remember Ruby.
- Yes, I do know Dr. Robinson
Jr.
He is an obstetrician
gynecologist too.
He was well ahead of me.
I think he was probably six
to eight years ahead of me,
but I knew him and the reason I
knew him,
I came here originally
as a research assistant
at Washington University,
but I lived in the dormitory
over here
and the people in OB-GYN found
out that I was interested
and so they would invite me down
and I would do delivery on the,
you know,
the watchful eyes and that's how
I met him
and the residents on his level.
- The difference in
working at a white hospital
and a black hospital like
Homer G. Phillips Hospital
was like dying and going to
heaven.
Just that was the
difference and it was a lot.
It was hard work though.
I mean we worked extremely hard,
but that was a good thing
because we developed a good work
ethic.
- Washington University was
the university affiliate
that gave us accreditation
to have a residency.
So all departments had
a great white father.
They were like, they knew
everything.
One time Dr. Monad, who
was our great white father,
had examined his patient and
said
the patient had an ovarian cyst.
We said, no, the patient's got
ascites,
which means a whole bunch
of fluid in the abdomen.
So Dr. Smiley said,
"Well, we need to wait and just
drain it."
So Dr. Monad said,
"We've got to take the
patient to surgery,"
because the abdomen and it's
like,
looks like she's nine months
pregnant.
Dr. Monad is going to do
the operation, you know,
because he gonna prove
to us colored people
that we didn't know what we
doing.
So knife cuts down, open her up,
when he tapped the perineum,
fluid squirted up to the light.
It was about 6,000 cc's.
That's like four gallons of
fluids.
So he was chagrin
because Smiley was right.
We're back in the back and
we're just cracking up.
Well see, those are the kind of
things,
the games we played, you know?
- During the discussions,
particularly around the nurses,
I mean,
physicians are fine, but when
we talk about the nurses,
what's really remarkable is the
fact
that they were driving a lot
of what was going on in the
hospital.
Now they don't wanna say that
openly,
but they really were just
remarkable driving force.
I heard all the backstories
about what goes on in the OR
and who really was moving things
along
and it's just almost like
the hidden figures story,
that really appealed to me
just hearing about those figures
that drove the excellence of the
hospital.
- I also think one thing
that's very important
about the hospital is that it
acted
as an engine of change
for many of these nurses and
doctors
that many people had, had come
from very poor backgrounds.
There were people who
came from the rural South
who'd never left their
communities,
but they somehow found the
means to leave their homes,
take a train or a bus,
take this journey to St.
Louis and start a new life
and by the time they
finished the nursing program
or their residency, they were
part of the middle class.
- The way I learned about Homer
Phillips
and the school of nursing,
while I was a junior in high
school,
I saw a brochure with
information about Homer Phillips
and it was in color,
and the young ladies were
in those beautiful uniforms.
It was the most beautiful thing
had seen
and I had always enjoyed
taking care of things.
So I said, that's for me.
And Ms. Minnie Eagle was the
director of nursing then,
so she accepted me.
So September of 1952
I ended up here in St. Louis,
at Homer G. Phillips
Hospital School of Nursing.
- I was born in Detroit,
Michigan.
How I became acquainted
with Homer G. Phillips
was that the nurses
came to my mother's home
when my sisters were born,
and so I watched their
performance in nursing care.
And I agreed with all of those
nurses.
- My sister used to
pick, was able to pick up
a PMOX in Monroe late at night
and she would hear about
the legacy of Homer Phillips
Hospital
and I always wanted to be a
nurse
and there was a Homer Phillips
graduate
and a Homer Phillips doctor
who had trained here,
a couple of them lived in my
city.
And Harriet Foster, who was
a Homer Phillips graduate,
encouraged my parents
to allow me to come to Homer
Phillips
and we were even featured in a
book
called The Warmth of Other Suns.
- I am from Jackson, Tennessee
and I have family members
who were employed here
and we did not have a hospital
for black people in Jackson.
And I came to St. Louis as a
child
and had my tonsils removed
at Homer Phillips hospital.
- I'm from Vicksburg,
Mississippi.
When I graduated from high
school in 1963,
Mercy Hospital there
head a nursing school,
but they did not accept blacks
and I was scheduled to
attend St. Mary's College
in St. Mary's, Kansas, and all
set to go
and one day in the early spring,
I walked through the principal's
office
and I saw that brochure
from Homer Phillips
and I'd said, well, you
know, may I have this?
And of course she was, it
was okay with her and I,
you know, read the whole
book and that was it.
- I lived about five miles
north from Homer G. Phillips.
I always felt I wanted to help
people,
but my parents really helped me
and inspired me to realize that
dream.
So not only was I born here,
but several of my other family
members
and then my daughter and my
mother as well worked here
as an OB over on One North,
which was the medical floor.
- I was born here in St. Louis
and my aunt, name is Estelle
Massey,
was a nurse here and I
wanted to be like her
and my dad would've talked me
into it,
he wanted me to be a nurse
I think because she was one.
- I'm from Evansville, Indiana,
and back in the '50s,
there were only two schools
accepting African American
students
and Homer G. Phillips was one
and that's how I ended
up in Homer G. Phillips.
Plus I was in the Future
Nurses Club in my high school
and the nurse's name was Jackson
and my maiden name is Jackson
and I wanted to be just like her
so that's how I ended up being a
nurse.
- I lived four or five blocks
from Homer Phillips as a child.
I recall many nights as a young
kid
and taken to Homer G. Phillips
Hospital
for one element or another.
I always, even as a young child,
remember wanting to take
care and heal people.
So nursing has always been in my
blood,
and Homer G. Phillips was
right in my neighborhood.
I was so very proud to see the
students
with their uniforms and their
white caps.
- I was born here in St. Louis
and I lived in The Ville,
so we were in walking distance.
I had six family members
that worked at Homer G.
Phillips.
So family was, the family
was full of medicine,
that was always my
desire to be in medicine.
- I was born in Memphis
and there was the nursing school
there
and in a crunch I got there,
they only took Caucasians
and so I was not accepted.
A lady in a church told us about
St. Louis
and Homer G. Phillips.
So all five kids got in the back
seat.
I was accepted and my
parents drove us up here
and put us in the hands
of the people at Homer G.
Phillips
and it was quite a reward.
- I remember Homer Phillips
about the age of 10 or 11,
because I had asthma and
I spent so many nights
at this hospital and so many
days,
weeks admitted to the pediatric
floor.
They didn't think I would
graduate high school
because I had to have teachers
to come tutor me in the
hospital.
Fortunately I did graduate
and I went to nursing school,
graduated and came back to Homer
Phillips
to work in that same emergency
room
with the same nurses that took
care me.
(laughter)
And it was just an awesome
feeling.
- When I arrived at Philips,
I was met by an upperclassman
and she was my mentor
and she continued to be my
friend throughout nursing.
She was just like an advisor
to sort of keep a country
girl straight.
You know, to learn the
rules, regulations.
Show me something about the
city.
Show me around the hospital
because it was a big place for
me.
Rules and regulations, you know,
things to do to have fun
and things to do to stay out of
trouble.
And a few things to get in
- [Jobyna] Our instructors were
excellent.
- [Woman In Gray] They
were, they were excellent.
- They would not accept
anything but excellence from us.
You had to excel to be a
Homer G. Phillips nurse.
You could not just walk out
in your uniform and cap.
You can not go down to Billy
Barks
as you heard them talk about
before
in your uniform and cap.
You could not go down to the
Blue Rooms
in your uniform and cap.
So we were taught those
high standards of nursing
and how to be a nurse in a
community
and take care of patients
and be well respected.
- One of the beautiful
things about the training
that we received as
nurses at Homer Phillips,
well, we were taught
to be all round person.
We would, we went to the
ballgames.
We went to the opera,
we went to the symphony,
we went to churches of
various denominations
because the feeling was
that to be a good nurse,
you need to be a rounded person
and we were exposed to all of
that
and I really appreciate it.
It has made me a better person.
- Our director of nurses
made an appointment
to go to Famous-Barr
that was a costume room,
The couture room.
It's one of these, like,
Bloomingdale and those kinds of
stores.
Well, Famous-Barr had a costume
room.
We were taken to the costume
room to get our shoes.
We would visit especially
made by an individual.
We were taken down there on the
bus
and each one of us individuals
would get measured for our
shoes.
We wore the high heeled granny
shoes,
long pointed toe if you've seen
it
with silk shoe strings
and they had to be clean
and straightened in your shoes.
They could not be twisted.
Those high heel shoes
were the most comfortable
shoes, that heel,
and we called them mother
clumpers.
We called them mother clumpers,
but they saved our feet.
You see, she wanted us to have
the best,
we always had the best.
Even when we had to fight for
it,
they fought for us to get the
best
or else we wouldn't
settle for anything less.
- There was Dr. Smiley, our
OB-GYN man.
The best OB-GYN doctor I've ever
seen.
We used to laugh in the
operating room.
He hummed all the time.
- Smiley, who was an OB GYN,
prided himself, as the doctors
all said,
he never said it, even
though he taught us OB-GYN,
that he could take out a
hysterectomy,
he'd do a hysterectomy in 20
minutes
and then when you talk to
those operating room nurses,
he was whistling the whole time
and doing this surgery and in 20
minutes,
the uterus is out,
tumor and everything else
going to the pathology lab.
That was Dr. Smiley, he
used that kind of speed.
- And he only used three
instruments,
hemostat, scissors,
Metzenbaum scissors
and the needle holder.
And he kept the scissors on his
finger
and he would flip them around.
He would suture, tie, cut,
and use wet sponge so
you didn't have to worry
about losing sponges in
patients at that time.
He was really good, he was
really fast.
- And he didn't ask you
for his instruments,
you were supposed to know, and
we did.
- The other thing we had to
learn
the anticipation of what
the doctor's going to need.
So therefore your instruments
were placed in that order.
Know he's gonna need his scalpel
first to make the incision,
you know secondly, he's
gonna need some clamps
or forceps as we call 'em,
to clamp off the blood vessels.
You may need your retractors
to pull back the muscles.
Then you're gonna need
certainly ready to suture up
after removing with the scissors
and all,
you're gonna need your
black silk or your cat gut,
your scissors, your needle and
thread.
- We were taught nursing was a
career.
I believe now as observation,
that nursing is a job and
it makes a difference.
- Most members of St. Louis
community
are aware of the school of
nursing here.
They are aware that doctors
trained here
as interns and residents.
But there were also three
other schools for students.
One was the school for
medical technologists,
one was the school for x-ray
technicians
and the third was the school
for medical record librarians.
That is the school that I
attended,
for medical record librarians.
I was one of those African
American babies
born in Homer Philips
during the time of segregated
health care
and I became aware of the
school and the profession
through our family physician
who was Dr. Julius Sherard.
He was also on the staff at
Homer Phillips
and very proud and supportive of
his wife,
Esther Sherard, who was the
founder
of the School for Medical Record
Librarians at Homer Phillips.
Medical record librarians today,
that title does not exist.
They're called health care
managers
and it reflects the digital
age we currently live in.
But when I was a student,
this is what we were called,
Medical Record Librarians,
and this was our bible.
This is the manual.
Students throughout the United
States
used this same textbook,
along with other textbooks,
but this was what taught us
how our jobs should be done.
- I think Homer G.
Phillips really achieved
its highest point ironically, I
guess,
just before desegregation
occurred
because there was so many
fabulously talented residents
who wanted to come here.
As these people came to
have other opportunities
in the United States,
not as many super talented
people
came to Homer G. Phillips
Hospital.
- It started as early as 1945,
with the Hill-Burton Act,
really putting hospitals on
notice
that they could not actively
discriminate,
but yeah, by the 1960s,
we really just start seeing
the inability to recruit
the top notch surgeons
of William Sinkler,
and James Whittico, and Dr.
Robinson.
- When we talked about
the closing of Homer G.,
there was rumors for a number of
years
'cause they said the city wanted
to get out of the hospital
business.
And so when it finally
came down,
I think Homer G. Phillips
was chosen over City
because the mayor felt it
was the easier thing to do.
He would get less drawback
from the white community
by closing Homer G. Phillips.
- Well, Homer Phillips
was on the closing block
from the time I came.
Every year, it would
come that the hospital
was going to be closed and by
the '70s,
into the mid '70s, it had
become more of an issue
that we were having meetings
with Washington University
and they had told us that well,
we are training more black
physicians than you are
because most of your physicians
now are foreign born.
- If you look at the list
of where the residents came from
early on
and compare that to a list
of where they came from
much later in the life of the
hospital,
you look down the list and
at the beginning it says,
Meharry, Meharry,
Meharry, Meharry, Meharry.
And if you look later on it's,
you know,
Guatemala, it's Mexico.
A lot of people were coming
from overseas at that point.
Some people felt too that the
city
had deliberately been pouring
resources
into other hospitals,
the Caucasian hospitals,
and that they had been
starving Homer G. Phillips
of some of the new equipment,
some of the technology that
they needed to do well.
- Homer G. Phillips Hospital
had been a major flashpoint
in the struggles of African
Americans in this community.
In 1973-'74, there was the usual
kind of community agitation
to save the hospital.
The major fight, the
biggest fight,
was about electing a black
comptroller.
And a black comptroller was
elected.
His name was John Bass,
and as a comptroller,
he has the power and the
authority
to determine what goes into the
budget.
So because we had an
African American in there
from 1973 to 1977
Homer G. Phillips was
essentially safe.
John Bass was defeated in March
of 1977.
The new comptroller that came
in,
his name was Raymond Percich.
He came in on the promise
along with the mayor of the city
then
Mayor Conway, that they
were going to close
Homer G. Phillips Hospital.
- Everybody knows what that was
all about.
The national health plan
was on the drawing board
and everybody would be a paying
customer.
It was the same way when I was a
kid.
Before food stamps,
there was Little Smile
Confectioneries
all through our neighborhood.
The big stores let you know
if you don't have any
money, don't come here.
The Little Confectionary says,
"We'll put it on the book
and when you get some money
we'll sign."
But when food stamps hit,
immediately, the stores
that didn't welcome us
put the big signs up.
"Welcome food stamps,"
and as a result of it,
a lot of the little
bitty stores shut down.
Well, the same thing with
the national health plan.
- In 1977 when all of us got
involved
in the efforts to save
the comptroller's position
and John Bass was defeated,
the whole community from that
point on
became an intense upheaval
in order to save this hospital.
- Every activist, you know,
from all corners, came together
and so that's how, you know,
I met Walle Amusa
when he became involved in the
struggle
to save Homer G. Phillips
Hospital.
We formed an ad hoc committee
to save Homer G. Phillips
Hospital
and all public hospitals.
- The radio disc jockey,
as we were known at the time,
personality disc jockeys,
were very involved in every
aspect of our community.
Most of the people that I spoke
with
around Homer G. Phillips
Hospital were ad hoc committees.
They would form committees
themselves to save the hospital
and they used my program as a
forum,
as a voice to communicate to the
community
and to tell them what was
happening,
to tell them where the meetings
were,
tell them why it was necessary
for you to come to the meetings.
If they wanted to keep
it open and they did.
- We got involved
when they were talking
about closing the hospitals.
They were going to close both
hospitals,
but they knew that the biggest
spike
was gonna come from this
hospital.
So the thing is don't
close Number One first
and allow the people at Homer
Phillips
to dig in the trenches and
really give you a fight.
Let's go at the big fight first
and if we're able to get
Homer Phillips closed,
when it comes time to close
Number One,
we can close that hospital
at that snap of a finger.
- [Walle] There were
demonstrations,
there were picket signs,
there were petitions,
there were sit ins in the
mayor's office.
- Everywhere James Conway,
who was the mayor,
would go for whatever event.
Someone from the ad hoc
committee
to save Homer G. Phillips
Hospital
will be there to ask questions.
We didn't care where, if it
was way South, we wound there
and, yes, we became
little shadows for him.
- We went down to the mayor's
office
where all of us got arrested,
but the mayor tried to
come out the normal way,
but we had the door blocked so,
but what was so strange,
he had these two huge
bodyguards on the outside
(laughter)
of the door.
- And about nine o'clock
police came and said,
you know, "You got to go.
The building gotta be closed."
They said, "No, we came to see
the mayor,
and we gonna be here until he
sees us."
So after a whole lot of
discussion, they said,
"If you don't leave,
we gonna lock you up."
So we said, "Lock us up."
We were on the second level,
they asked us to go
down to the first floor
to get in a paddy wagon.
We said no.
- [Julia] They had to
carry us out on stretchers
from the second floor.
(laughter)
- They were really tired when
they got finished with us.
- It's funny now, but
it was not funny then
because I think we were all
afraid.
- The protests were organized
and we marched through the
community.
We marched downtown.
We've marched everywhere that we
could
to draw attention to the fact
that we were losing this
and we knew that if you lose the
hospital,
you lost the community.
(foreboding music)
- It only took two votes
on the Board of Estimate and
Apportionment
in order to put money in the
budget
to save this hospital, to keep
it running,
and it didn't come to a
real flashpoint until 1978
when the comptroller made a
promise
that he will not put a
penny
into the 1979 budget
to operate this facility here.
So essentially the hospital was
closed
because we had an irresponsible,
racist,
uncaring politician in the
name of Raymond Percich
that colluded with the mayor to
get it.
Two votes out of three
to take money out of the
budget that would be used,
you know that, to continue
to operate this facility.
- The day that they closed the
hospital,
I was at home, they had
told us all to take off
and like I lived on the
backside of the hospital.
So I heard helicopters, you
know,
flying in the neighborhood
and I'm thinking,
"What the devil is that?"
and then when I looked across
the street,
I saw all of these police cars.
- I was at work as a
head nurse on One North.
And they had stopped
hospital admissions now.
Homer G. Phillips in the
African American community,
the emergency room was
always accepting patients.
So that was really strange
and then if people became aware
that they had brought moving
trucks,
then I went to the switchboard
to let folks know that they were
coming
to close the hospital.
And then everybody kinda
got in and alerting
and notified their neighbors,
people in the nearby community
were,
you know, in the streets
and folks that were coming to
work
was finding out that the
hospital,
you know, was closed.
And they were transferring
patients
and removing equipment and stuff
from Homer G. Phillips and
that was August the 17th, 1979.
- I was here at the day
that the hospital was
actually forcibly closed.
I had started coming my usual
way
over Annie Malone Drive,
which was a good avenue at that
time
and I was met with the police.
See, we did not have
cell phones at that time
and the first act was to
cut off the switchboard.
So we could not make, no one
could make a call in or out.
- [Walle] The community rose up
in arms,
basically surrounded this
hospital.
(knocking)
- And I had never seen
anything like that before.
It was just amazing that
they had that much
police, you know, policemen
that kind of police
power over there.
I didn't know what they
were expecting or anything,
but it was, it was something.
- You had politicians, you had
ministers,
you had students, you had young
people.
Congressman Bill Clay, you know,
his office was here every
day around the clock.
Senator Gwen Giles,
Marion Ross, Alderwoman Marion
Ross,
Alderman Freeman Bosley.
They were literally under siege
for this,
surrounded this hospital
for almost 20 days.
- People were quite beside
themselves
and upset and emotional,
you know, even as they tried
to take care of their patients
The ones that were there,
and be normal or routine,
but still the tension, you know,
and the nervousness and
anxiety was shown by,
you know, by all, I mean, some
people were actually crying.
- It is important for the record
to show
that this community did
not give up this hospital.
It was stolen.
- Their goal was to get in,
sneak in, sneak attack, shut it
down,
get everybody out of there
and do what they had to do
and that's the way they handled
it.
Rather than telling the
public at a particular time,
"We will be here and we
were going to shut it down,"
and there would have
been a much larger crowd.
Even the staff and people like
that,
they didn't let them know,
they found out the day
that people were coming
to close, shut the doors down.
- The closing of this hospital
was a military operation.
It was 5 AM in the morning,
helicopters,
police dogs,
police man on their horses.
The state national guard put on
notice
and it took that kind
of a military operation
to snatch
a jewel
from the people in this
community.
- Officially, the city might say
that they closed Homer G.
Phillips on August the 19th,
that's the, you know, the
official,
that's just like
pronouncing somebody dead.
They pronounced Homer G.
Phillips
dead to them on August the 19th.
Well, it was really August
the 17th to the community.
- What you see here is just an
office.
You say, what is the
significance of this office?
This is the site of the new
Homer G.Phillips emergency room.
It was built approximately 1977
to '78
and the hospital didn't close in
1979.
And many people said the
city just spent $2 million
on a new the emergency room,
they're certainly not going to
close Homer Phillips Hospital.
And some of us said, if you
don't vote,
if you don't participate,
you won't get what you want.
And indeed, the hospital
was closed in 1979.
- To have the hospital closed
under the circumstances
was just a horrible affront
to the
consciousness of those who
really believed that their,
their legacy as African
Americans was really based
on that hospital and so to have
that close
under cover of darkness
and then to have a protest next
day
only met with
police with dogs
and the cars
really to those African
Americans in St. Louis,
it resembled the Bull
Connor days of Birmingham.
And it just, it conjured those
images
and it just really created a lot
of,
a lot of apathy, a lot of anger
which is really difficult to
discharge
after all these years.
Some of that's still there.
- If you notice the people
and the organizations that
closed
Homer G. Phillips Hospital,
they were not of St. Louis.
It wasn't that important to
them.
Like black radio.
It's not important to some
people.
It's like other black
institutions, like HBCUs.
It's not important to those
who are outside of it.
You have to be a part of it to
feel that,
that love for it and to support
that love
and support the structure
itself.
If you just check out who closed
Homer G. Phillips Hospital,
who was involved, and you'll see
that they didn't care about,
not only Homer G. Philips
Hospital,
but African Americans in
general.
- This is a sweatshirt that my
daughter
who was seven to eight at the
time,
around the struggle to
reopen the hospital,
and she just adored this,
and it says, "Vote yes, Homer G.
Phillips,
"April the 7th, Campaign
for Human Dignity."
And this is another
prized treasure.
"Reopen Homer G. Phillips,
Campaign for Human Dignity."
- The fight to reopen the
hospital began immediate.
The first level of action
of course was to defeat
the mayor
who made the decision
to close the hospital.
We led a major, you know,
campaign here
to defeat Mayor Conway
and another mayor was elected
who promised to reopen the
hospital,
that was Mayor Vincent
Schoemehl.
He got in there, of course
he broke his promise.
In the meantime, we had to
then resort to petitions.
We had two petitions
that went on the ballot
to reopen the hospital.
Unfortunately, two of those
petitions got more than
50%.
The required percentage was 67%
because South St. Louis,
which was predominantly white,
voted overwhelmingly against
reopening this hospital
but there were racial politics
plays in this country,
where they used blacks against
whites,
whites against blacks,
and then by the time they get
through,
most poor whites and poor blacks
are left
to just fend for themselves.
- People who knew the hospital
and knew the community
and knew its importance
to the black community,
worked hard to try to
keep it open to no avail,
but it, a gallant fight to
make sure it would stay open.
Then they came back
later to try to make sure
it was not torn down
because there was talk
about tearing the whole building
down.
I think there's pride, the
fact that it's still here.
- When I first arrive at the
site to accept the position
it was interesting to
see that the hospital
looked totally different
than what it looks now
and that was in 2002,
so that was the very first year
that the facility opened for
residents.
- I was looking for a place to
live.
My husband was in the hospital
and he was not going to survive
very long,
I was told that, so I had to
make some changes in my life.
So I began to downsize and I
looked around the community
for senior citizens buildings
and I got turned down a couple
of times
and I turned some down.
But when I came here,
there was a gentleman in
the hall that said to me,
"Excuse me, ma'am, is your
name Sandra Williams?"
and Sheila who works in the
office here
and my daughter said,
"Oh, there's somebody who knows
you here."
And yes he did.
He remembered me because he
had been one of my supervisors
in another health department.
So I was like, "Well,
this must be the place
that God has sent me to."
- I needed a place with 24
security,
you know, I needed a
place where on the inside
I didn't wanna be by myself
and someone told me about Homer
G.
And I happened to come
and look around one day
and I'm looking at the
amenities, not the people.
They had a beauty salon there.
I got my beauty shop license.
They had barbershop, they
had the doctor's office,
they had 24 security.
They had a grocery store.
If I didn't feel like
cooking, they had a cafe.
I'm like, "Wow, this sounds
like the promised land
that's in the Bible," you know,
once you cross that joint and
go through all them problems,
you know, the promised
land is there.
And that's what I called
it when I came in.
This is the promised land.
- Personally, in order to
destroy a landmark like they did
and then some others from out of
town,
and out of state come in to
refurbish it
and say this is a good thing
for making living quarters for
profit,
I thought it was disgraceful.
I thought Homer G. Phillips
Hospital never should've closed,
but had it reopened, I
think I should reopen
partially as a hospital at
least.
And for them to do what
they've done to it,
although it's a beautiful
structure,
I think it's disgraceful
personally.
- [Nathaniel] I was impressed
with what it had become to
be very honest with you.
When I walked in that front
door,
I didn't know it was Homer
Phillips.
You know, it was gone.
It's not Homer Phillips to me.
- This building's stood as a
model
certainly within the city of St.
Louis
of what a senior living
for seniors could become
and so it was the first time
where we saw a full
service senior building.
We set the standard for that
really here
and so that is another
testament to Homer G. Phillips.
Where we once again become
the symbol of excellence
and how it is that we
look towards what this,
how this should be done,
and so I give a lot of credit
to the management company
and to Miss Sharon Robnett,
who was one of the African
American partners in this
that had a vision for a
full service community.
- When I look at the building
today,
I think about what it was.
You feel sad but you also feel
proud.
It was a special point of your
life.
You are able to experience
something you can share.
I can talk about what was,
which gives me hope of what
could be.
But at the same time I realize
it's a special place in time
that probably will never happen
again.
Why is it that these
communities have reunions?
As bad as they say they were,
why is that people come back
each year for a reunion?
Because it's a special place to
them
and it has special meaning to
them.
- In this case, there are side
mirrors,
Homer G. Phillips nurses,
a photograph of Sarah Jane
Banks.
She was a wife of St.
Louis artist Spencer Banks,
Ellen Bolton Brown, class of
1947.
She was also last director of
nursing
at Homer G. Phillips.
Ms. Helen Pipes Blackwell, class
of 1942.
She was also an instructor
at Homer G. Phillips.
Mrs. Velma Jones,
she was a nurse in the class of
1943,
and also she was the first
African American nurse
who worked at Barnes Hospital
and she passed away 2010 at the
age of 91.
And down here, Dr. Eugene
Mitchell,
he was a director of medical
at Homer G. Phillips.
He was also a graduate
of the University of
Missouri Medical School,
third African American to be
admitted
and the first African American
to graduate
from the University of Missouri.
Okay, over here, you see various
artifacts
of Homer G. Phillips Hospital
doctors,
a table, a chair,
here's a medical table
and a lot of photographs
and newspaper clippings.
Year books and equipment
that was at Homer G. Phillips.
Also have a couple of the capes.
This cape belonged to Mrs. Velma
Jones,
and the cap here belonged
to Miss Lula Hall.
Here's another Cape that
belonged
to a Miss Mary Lane Crawford,
and then in the center
here, you got a uniform
that also belonged to Velma
Jones
when she was a nursing cadet
that she, yeah, she graduated in
1945.
- I was able to come over
during the renovations
and I was pleased, happy,
delighted.
Kind of fearful, not
knowing what I would find,
wanted so very badly to go to
my division, my old division,
which was pediatrics originally.
I asked the gentleman if he
would take me up to fifth floor,
which is the fifth floor of this
hospital
on the south side, Five South,
and the feeling that came
over me was of
sadness. I almost wanted to cry
as I feel now.
And all that I could remember
was the two wards which
extended east and west
on the south side of the
building
where we housed over 105
patients
at one time.
We would have patients
coming down the middle.
They would be on either sides of
the wards
in the heat when we did
not have air conditioning,
and it came back to me that
we never lost a patient.
Out of those 104 children
that we took care of
that summer when it was such
a heat wave here in St. Louis,
we didn't have adequate staff.
But the skeleton staff that
we had on 7:00 to 3:30 shift,
the 3:00 to 11:00 shift,
and 11:00 to 7:00 shift
when we only had two nurses
took care of those children.
Those were the memories
that came back to me
and I must have stayed up
there with the gentlemen
for a good 20 minutes
and he just asked that we move
along
because he could see
that I was filling up,
I can see it all over again.
I love this place.
It will never leave my memory
and I'm so proud and so glad
that those 300 and some dollars
my mother and father
sacrificed to send me here
and the one year that
I worked to help myself
to come to nursing school.
I am happy to say I am
proud to be
a Homer Phillips nurse.
Thank you very much,
I love coming in here.
(approving murmurs)
- She said it all.
She said it all.
(applause)
- I'm from Tupelo, Mississippi,
I spent my teen years here in
St. Louis
before going away to college
and then moved back here to
work at Washington University.
I've been teaching the
Homer G. Phillips course,
which is Homer G. Phillips:
The Patient, Physician and
Community for five years.
The class was developed probably
about 10 to 15 years prior
because Washington University
realized
that they had a number of
students,
especially underrepresented
minorities,
who were interested in health
when starting Wash. U.,
but weren't applying in the
same percentages and numbers.
- My family was very excited to
learn
that I was taking a whole
course on Homer G. Phillips
and not just visiting there for
one day
because it meant a lot to them.
A lot of us were like born
there.
So there was a lot of family
connection
and how much it meant to
the St. Louis community
when they lived here still.
They live mostly in
Springfield and Kansas now
so not too much here in St.
Louis,
but Homer G. was a driving
force in their community
and to know that I'm in my
generation
and still learning about it,
it's still impacting our
family, meant a lot to them.
- And so the first part of the
course,
we go to The Ville, we figure
out what The Ville is about.
We study the hospital.
With that, I wanted to
kind of teach the lessons
that come from Homer G. Phillips
and that is the fact that the
physician
is oftentimes more than the
physician.
He's part of the community,
she's part of the community,
so she's not just taking care
of particular health needs,
she's taking care of the whole
being.
I think those are the principles
that are important to
instill in the students.
- No matter what I did after
college,
I knew that I wanted to help
people.
That was my main goal
and I think that taking,
particularly taking the Homer G.
Course
helped me solidify that
because it gave all of us
an opportunity to see just the
different black professionals
that have devoted their
lives to helping others
and it also gave us an
opportunity
to volunteer and work with
children
at the children's hospital.
It really helped me
see that helping people
is when I felt like I was
doing something important,
I guess I would say,
it's kind of an understatement,
but yeah.
- We want our students,
if they really want to help
people
and they really believe that
health care
is that route that we help them
and equip them with the tools
but we can't do that without
community.
Our physicians couldn't
do that without community
when they were at Homer G.
Phillips
and then they can't do it
out the community as well.
- Homer G. Phillips is just
it's really
a major point
that highlights a bigger
dynamic here in St. Louis.
And the impact that
we've had on the nation,
particularly with regards to
the civil rights movement.
Most of your major civil rights
and legal components started
right here in St. Louis
going back to the Dred Scott
Case
and it goes on and on and on.
The Urban League was developed
as a result
of what took place here in St.
Louis,
all the way up to the present
with the Ferguson situation.
And so this speaks volumes
as to the rich culture
that has evolved here in St.
Louis,
and that can continue to grow.
And I believe that this is gonna
certainly
put a fire in the community
to really take a passion
in what we've accomplished over
the years.
- It's literally a who's who
among St. Louis titans, right?
And so, you know, we have
people from Dick Gregory
and Tina Turner and so everybody
from every walk of life,
Grace Bumbry, like, it's just
an amazing place to be at.
I heard from an alumni,
the actual Chuck Berry
performed in this very room.
It used to be the auditorium
and now it's our library.
But you just see those
sorts of things all the time
with our school and who we are,
we're working tirelessly
to get back to that point and
even extend
and so that's what we're
really excited about.
- My name is Becky
and my father is Dr. Earle U.
Robinson Jr.
Ever since I was a little girl,
I remember my father
always telling stories
about when he was a little boy,
when he was living in Atlantic
City
when he went off to college,
when he went to medical
school, ups and downs.
There's so many things.
My father has just been such
an integral part of my life
and he's taught me so much
and that's probably why I am
the person that I am today
is because of him and his
philosophies and things like
that.
But at this time in his life,
I know that he's
getting to the age
where his health is a factor
and I,
I really want other
people to be able to know
more about my father
and how he played an
important role in medicine.
Just as a person and as a
father.
One thing that really touched me
is when I finally drove
up to the hospital.
This is my first time in St.
Louis
and I live in Indianapolis
and it's only, you know,
a four hour drive and
it was just interesting
that I had never been in St.
Louis before
and I'm coming down that street
and pulling up to the hospital.
I've seen all these pictures
and I didn't know what I would
feel
when I first got here.
But I felt a sense that
it was the right timing.
It was meant to be and I'm
doing something super amazing
for not just my grandfather,
but for my father and my family.
Within the entrance,
I saw this picture years ago,
my grandfather was standing
next to this stairway
and I didn't know exactly where
it was
and I assumed it was, you know,
the entrance of the Homer
G. Phillips Hospital.
But you know, now that it's
a retirement living home,
I walked in, was shown
that it was the steps
that my father,
my grandfather originally stood
next to
and the one thing that I wanted
to do
was stand right there and be
able to be
in the same place that
my grandfather stood
and I told Joyce, I said,
"Please take a picture.
I have to send this to
my father right away,"
and I called my father
later on that afternoon
to let him know that I
walked in the hospital,
that I got to stand
right there at the steps
and the first thing my father
said,
"Your grandfather is extremely
proud,"
and I just, you know, let him
know
that it's a dream come true.
Originally, my father and I,
we discussed about doing this
project
and he wasn't sure if it was
gonna happen,
but I think every day
that I see that this team
is working so hard to make this
happen,
this film is happening and I'm
just,
I'm just grateful and I'm
just really passionate
about what I do and what I put
my mind to
and I'm just so thankful.
I really am.
♪ Brown melanin be unintelligent
♪
♪ Original originator
royal bound heritage ♪
♪ Skin tough as leather rent
and endure whatever weather's ♪
♪ In this pressure it's 50
shades of it no sexin' flicks ♪
♪ Take a second listen enjoy its
beauty ♪
♪ But it's truly a truth so
please ♪
♪ Don't give it negligence
♪ Its scars tell a story
about defiance in glory ♪
♪ Ask some black history books
♪ All that white is boring me
♪ The blacker the berry
the sweeter juice ♪
♪ Media got us thinking
the blacker the worse ♪
♪ Taste the juice
♪ The world mainly black juice
said they disrespect you ♪
♪ I'm here today to tell you
♪ Don't trip your skill is harm
♪
♪ They hung us they stumped us
they yelled out they hate us ♪
♪ Denied us the freedom they
robbed us and raped us ♪
♪ The world is against us in
the corner they placed us ♪
(tense music)